en este momento la teoría que prevalece
acerca de la creación del universo se
llama comúnmente el 'big bang' o teoría
de la gran explosión y es simplemente
esta idea de que todo el universo
comenzó
a partir de un punto infinitamente
pequeño o también llamada singularidad
en el cual se dio una gran explosión que
hizo que se expandiera desde ese punto
infinitamente pequeño hasta el tamaño
que existe en la actualidad y
normalmente la primera vez que uno
escucha este concepto se imagina algo
como una explosión que uno conoce en el
que pues todo está infinitamente
empaquetado en un lugar muy muy muy muy
pequeño y después se explota y se
expande hacia afuera y así pues bueno
toda la materia que explota más adelante
se empieza a condensar formando galaxias
que a su vez comenzaron a condensarse y
formar estrellas y sistemas planetarios
y toda la materia que conocemos
pero esto no es la forma correcta de
visualizar esta teoría uno de los
problemas que tiene es que cuando
hablamos de la gran explosión no estamos
hablando de la explosión de una materia
o masa
es que toda la masa que conocemos o la
materia hubiera estado empaquetada en un
solo lugar
de hecho el espacio en sí mismo estaba
también en ese punto no es que explotara
algo dentro de otra cosa que ya
existiera todo el universo el espacio y
la materia es lo que se encuentra en
este punto previo a la explosión al
darse la explosión y tener toda la
materia aquí en este borde nos
preguntamos qué es lo que hay aquí
afuera
bueno no puede ser espacio porque el
espacio mismo es lo que está
expandiéndose en esta explosión si esa
es la materia y el espacio que están en
el borde de la explosión será este el
borde del universo
el límite del universo
y la respuesta a esta pregunta es que
primero el universo no tiene un borde o
un límite
y no hay nada fuera del espacio fuera
del universo no nos estamos expandiendo
dentro de otra cosa que ya existiera y
vamos a ver cuál es la razón detrás de
estas respuestas
la mejor forma de entender esto es
mediante analogías si yo les dijera que
tengo
un espacio de dos dimensiones
espacio de dos dimensiones
que tiene un área finita
área finita o sea no es infinito
y tampoco tiene un borde
no tiene borde o límite si lo vemos en
un principio pues podría ser difícil de
imaginar algo así construir algo que
tenga un área finita pero no tenga un
límite o no tenga un borde pero quizás
ustedes se pueden imaginar un espacio de
dos dimensiones pero que esté curvado
que sea curvo y el ejemplo más sencillo
esto es la superficie de una esfera
vamos a dibujar una esfera más o menos
así vamos a dibujar una latitud y
longitud en esta esfera y vamos a
ponerle un poquito de sombra para que se
note bien el volumen de esta esfera
en este tipo de esfera se tiene un área
finita y no se tienen bordes o límites
si ustedes caminan alrededor de esta
superficie pueden seguir caminando en
cualquier dirección todo el tiempo sin
llegar a un límite o algo que les impida
seguir caminando
para imaginarse un espacio de tres
dimensiones que tengan las mismas
propiedades que no tengan límites y
bueno no quiere decir que no tenga área
finita porque ya no estaríamos hablando
de dos dimensiones vamos a escribirlo
por acá estamos pensando en un espacio
de tres dimensiones
espacio tridimensional
y en lugar de hablar de áreas ya que
estamos hablando de tres dimensiones
hablaremos de volúmenes finitos
volumen finito
y 100 bordes o límites
si hablamos de volúmenes pues podríamos
tener aquí este cubo
aunque pues aquí obviamente tenemos
bordes que bueno no debemos tener debido
a la definición de lo que buscamos
tampoco nos sirve el volumen de una
esfera ya que la esfera tiene un borde
en la parte exterior así que como
podemos construir un espacio
tridimensional que tenga un volumen
finito y sin bordes y bueno les puedo
decir que esto es tremendamente difícil
para nosotros de imaginar y de hecho es
algo que no podemos dibujar ustedes
tienen que imaginarse por analogía a
menos que tengan una mente muy brillante
que pueda imaginarse cosas de más de
tres dimensiones tener una esfera pero
déjenme aclarar algo esta es una
superficie de dos dimensiones
y al estar en la superficie sólo podemos
movernos en las direcciones de izquierda
a derecha adelante y atrás así que es la
superficie de dos dimensiones
una esfera
de una esfera de tres dimensiones
si hacemos la analogía vamos a imaginar
aunque es difícil una superficie de tres
dimensiones y esto se puede hacer
matemáticamente y de hecho no es tan
difícil hacerlo matemáticamente la
superficie tridimensional de una esfera
de cuatro dimensiones y trataré de
dibujarla de la misma manera si
pudiéramos imaginar que estas tres
dimensiones fueran solamente las dos
dimensiones de este dibujo de la misma
manera
y si se lo imaginan aunque obviamente
esto no es la verdadera forma del
universo no sabemos cuál es la forma
real del universo pero si sabemos que
tiene una ligera curvatura usamos la
esfera como analogía porque es la más
sencilla aunque podríamos usar otros
volúmenes y quiero aclarar algo de hecho
no sabemos a ciencia cierta si tiene un
volumen finito aún es una pregunta sin
responder pero lo que quiero mostrarles
aquí es que se puede tener un volumen
finito sin bordes y de hecho la mayoría
de la gente cree
y digo cree porque no hay alguna
evidencia que respalde esta creencia de
que estamos hablando de algo con un
volumen finito especialmente si hablamos
de la teoría de la gran explosión pues
en cierto sentido implica un volumen
finito ahora si ustedes se han imaginado
esta esfera
si estuvieran en la superficie de esta
esfera de cuatro dimensiones que de
hecho bueno no la puedo dibujar en la
realidad tendrán que usar su imaginación
si estuviera en la superficie de esta
esfera de cuatro dimensiones podrían ir
en cualquier dirección izquierda derecha
adelante atrás arriba abajo y podrían
regresar al mismo punto sin encontrar
ningún límite ahora el universo es
enorme de manera que incluso a la luz
que es lo más veloz que existe le tome
una cantidad de tiempo tremenda poder
dar la vuelta a este volumen finito y
además si la esfera en sí misma se está
expandiendo puede estarse expandiendo
tan rápido que la luz nunca alcance a
darle la vuelta a todo el volumen
recordamos que esta es una superficie de
tres dimensiones en una esfera de cuatro
dimensiones si esto fuera cierto y bueno
aquí no puedo yo dibujar
todas las dimensiones en esta superficie
significa que si nos vamos también hacia
arriba
y continuamos yendo hacia arriba
eventualmente vamos a regresar a nuestro
punto de origen vamos a ver si lo puedo
dibujar si vamos hacia arriba
eventualmente vamos a regresar por abajo
quizás sea una distancia increíblemente
larga pero eventualmente se llegaría de
nuevo al punto de partida lo mismo
sucede si nos vamos hacia uno de los
lados o si nos vamos hacia adelante o
hacia atrás
en cualquier caso eventualmente
regresaremos hacia el punto de partida
aquí se trata de dibujar todas las
dimensiones en donde podríamos estar
haciendo este recorrido y realizar al
mismo punto bueno regresemos a la
pregunta acerca del universo en
expansión un universo que no se está
expandiendo dentro de otra cosa ya
existente donde el espacio mismo es el
que se está expandiendo bueno ese es el
modelo si ustedes pueden imaginar poco
después de la gran explosión nuestra
esfera de cuatro dimensiones
se vería más o menos
antes de la gran explosión este puntito
está toda la materia y el espacio y una
fracción de tiempo después tenemos esta
esfera
que está un poquito más grande y un poco
después esa esfera podría verse más o
menos así ahora bueno ustedes podrían
verse tentados en decir bueno porque no
hay cosas afuera de la esfera no hay
algún espacio en el que se esté
expandiendo la esfera y les puedo decir
que si estamos hablando de tres
dimensiones no esto no es posible
pues el universo entero es esta
superficie la superficie de esta esfera
de cuatro dimensiones y si comenzamos a
hablar de más dimensiones bueno entonces
sí sí sería posible quizás existan cosas
fuera de nuestro universo de tres
dimensiones así que esto se está
expandiendo en el espacio y en el tiempo
si pensáramos que el tiempo es la cuarta
dimensión entonces las cosas estarían
alejándose cada vez más entre ellas y
veremos más evidencia en otros vídeos
del por qué la teoría de la gran
explosión o el 'big bang' es la mejor
teoría que existe acerca de la creación
del universo imaginen ustedes que yo
dibujo dos puntos en la superficie de
esta esfera y que ésta se está
expandiendo qué va a pasar con estos
puntos a pues estos puntitos se van a
alejar más entre ellos y una de las
cosas que da sentido a esta teoría es
que realmente todos los objetos en el
universo se están alejando mutuamente en
cualquier punto del universo ustedes
podrían observar que todo lo que está
alrededor se está alejando de ustedes
y mientras más lejos vamos da la
impresión de que se está alejando a más
velocidad vamos a dejar estos conceptos
aquí para que ustedes puedan pensar al
respecto puedan reflexionar sobre ellos
y después veremos lo que hemos aprendido
al observar el universo